So I've been getting a ton of emails from
the supporters of different presidential candidates
who are getting in touch and saying, David,
you have to cover something about this one
candidate who made the next debate or didn't
make the next debate or whatever.
And then I got a lot of emails from people
who aren't supporting those candidates saying,
David, please don't do an entire story about
how X is going to the debate or why is going
to, the debate is not going to the debate.
This is not worthy of a full segment.
So here's how I'll make everybody happy or
no one happy, which is let's just do a Roundup
of what's going on with the debate next week,
which is the sixth democratic debate.
Uh, Andrew Yang has qualified for the next
debate on December 19th, Tulsi Gabard has
announced she's not going to the next debate,
even though she hasn't qualified.
So it's not really much of a choice.
Kama Harris has qualified but has dropped
out of the campaign and won't be going.
And then there is discussion about whether
the DNC is going to change the rules to allow
Michael Bloomberg to maybe qualify for future
debates.
So let's go through these one by one.
As of right now, the qualified candidates
for debate number six are Biden Sanders, Warren
booted, judge Clover, char, Tom Stier, Andrew
Yang, and Kamala Harris.
That's eight.
But as I mentioned, Kamala Harris has ended
her presidential campaign and won't be attending.
As I said last week, I respect this.
It's very tempting.
Even if you know you can't win the nomination
to just stick it out and get another night
in front of the cameras on public, on national
television.
Camila chose not to do it and I respect her
for doing that.
Then we had this big announcement from tool
C Gabard where she said on Twitter quote,
for a number of reasons, I've decided not
to attend the December 19th quote debate regardless
of whether or not there are qualifying polls.
I think he means regardless of whether there
are qualifying quote polls, I instead choose
to spend that precious time directly meeting
with and hearing from the people of New Hampshire
and South Carolina.
Now, Tulsi happens to be polling literally
zero and two of the most recent six national
polls.
She's not qualified for the debate and she
is unlikely to qualify for that debate, so
she's using this as a PR stunt saying she
won't be attending.
Well, yeah, we know you didn't make it.
You're not invited and that's fine.
She won't be clogging up the stage.
I'm glad for her to tweet whatever she wants.
The concern that's growing is that she's setting
up this adversarial public thing with the
DNC to eventually announced that she's running
third party, which would have a very unpredictable
effect.
We will dig in more to that if it actually
happens.
Then we have Andrew Yang qualifying a polling
for in the last Quinnipiac poll, four in the
latest morning consult poll.
So he's in and maybe this time he will be
actually allowed to say more than just a couple
of things.
He got very little talk time in debate number
five on MSNBC, so that's great news for Andrew
Yang.
Now lastly, let's talk about Michael Bloomberg.
Bloomberg is actually polling okay.
So far.
He very quickly has gotten a five in a couple
of polls, six in a recent poll.
His issue is he's not taking donations, which
is an issue in the sense that there's a donor
requirement to make the debates, so there's
a few articles floating around about how the
DNC is going to have a choice to make.
Do they want to get rid of the donor requirement
in order to give Bloomberg the possibility
of making the debates.
Now, I don't know that the DNC wants Bloomberg
on the stage.
It seems sort of lose lose for them if they
changed the rules and let Bloomberg into the
debate.
Assuming he gets the required polling support,
every other candidate would rightly flip out
and say, that's not fair.
We've all had five debates, six debates already
with the rules.
Now the rules are changed for Bloomberg halfway
through or it's getting towards the end of
the debate season.
They would be right to flip out at the same
time.
Imagine that all of Bloomberg's campaign ad
spending works and he keeps pulling five,
six, even 7% not having him on the stage is
sort of weird because he would be pulling
much better than a number of the candidates
that do make the stage.
But these are the rules of the DNC set and
as we know that you know, live by the rules,
die by the rules.
I have no idea what they will do.
So my question to you is, aside from the reality
that number one, we don't need another billionaire
on stage and number two, buying your way onto
the stage is just the sickening reality of
status quo, political campaign financing and
we're disgusted by it.
If Bloomberg is polling five or six, should
he be on the debate stage?
From the purposes of participating in the
conversation.
I don't have an answer.
I want to hear from you
about it.